i'm kit harrington this is the wired
auto complete interview
who was ken who was carrington on
friends i wasn't actually on friends
okay is kit harrington is kit harington
his real name
actually my real name is christopher
harrington but my
my parents always called me kit so
that's so i'm kit really but on my
passport i'm christopher harrington is
kit harington in house of the dragon
no i asked to be but um they weren't
having it that's not true
is kit harrington
what's that
a main character in the eternals i'm
going to go ahead and say i'm the main
character in the eternals i'm dane
whitman he's the lead character is kit
harrington
in modern love
yes yes kate harrington is in modern
love season two
who we're on to the who's
who
i'm guessing that is who
who was ken who was carrington on
friends it wasn't actually on friends
that's a that's a confused question
who
what do you think it is who does
who does kit harrington support i'm
guessing that's football team and i
support manchester united
i'm trying different techniques to get
them off it who
does kate harrington look like
christopher abbott apparently he's a
great actor i'm very happy to look like
christopher abbott
who does kit harrington play in zog it's
like one of those ones where you should
know the answer
i'm going to pass on that
what does kit harrington
look like now
bit like this i guess
what does kit harrington
use in his hair
uh
just sort of
general
body grease and dirt
what
glasses
does kit harrington
where
a couple of pairs with a couple of pairs
of glasses
what is kit harrington
doing
now
such a depressing question
yeah this currently this
what is kit harrington
doing next i'm probably gonna have a
coffee i think
um
coffee and a sit down all right
how
is
kit harrington
how is kit harrington kit harrington is
well today thank you he's doing he's
doing well a little nervous about these
questions but how
old is kit harrington
25.
how old was
kit harrington
in season one of game of thrones 21.
how did kit harrington
become an actor by mistake
i think
by one glorious mistake many years ago
when i decided that i'd get up and
show off for a living
kit harrington
accent english kit harrington
karaoke no kit harrington
tattoo
no
kit harrington
vegan unfortunately not but thinking
about it quite seriously now kit
harrington
work out occasionally when i'm feeling
um
ambitious
is kit harrington is kit harrington
[Music]
in lord of the rings
no is kit harrington a singer
yes
yes he is
not not often known that but he is a
very good singer is kit harrington
british yup
for my sins is kit harrington
a law
no
no not according to wikipedia but i'm
not
did
kit harrington
keep longclaw no and he's still bitter
about it uh hbo kept longclaw so you can
ask them does kit harrington
have siblings yeah i have one brother
he's called jack i love him to bit did
kit harrington
win any awards not a single one
not one not bitter about that either
does kit harring if i have to say my own
name one more time does kit harrington
have powers in eternals
no actually no he doesn't
he doesn't thank you wired i've
thoroughly enjoyed knowing what people
search about me on the internet
[Music]